There's one more refinement to
the algorithm that I can't resist, and
that's due to Dinic.
He actually published his algorithm in
1970, two years before Edmonds-Karp.
His key insight is that the work
of computing the shortest path
can be recycled so that a full
recomputation only needs to happen when
the shortest path distance changes,
not for every augmenting path.
As with all augmenting path strategies,
we start with an initial flow of 0.
Then we repeat the following.
We build the level graph from
the residual flow network, and
let k be the shortest
path length from s to t.
Then, while there's a path from source
to sink in the level graph that has
length k, we will augment
the flow along that path and
then update the residual capacities.
And we repeat this until there are no
more s-t paths in the residual network.
And finally we just return the flow.
Turning to the analysis,
we will call one iteration
of this outer loop a phase.
And we will be able to argue that
each phase increases the length
of the shortest s-t path in
the residual network by one.
The principle here is the same as for
Edmonds-Karp.
Augmenting by a shortest
path flow doesn't create
a shorter augmenting flow.
Hence, once we've exhausted
all paths of a given length,
the next shortest path
must be one edge longer.
Within a phase, the level graph is
built by breadth-first search, so
that only costs order E time.
The hardest part of the argument will
be that this loop altogether takes only
E times V time.
We'll see this argument in a second.
Altogether, we will show that Dinic's
algorithm takes E times V squared time,
which is an improvement over the E
squared V time of Edmonds-Karp.